look it's been a long time since we've
talked about it okay
it really is it's sparing it's whatever
now
this is a scenario where i actually
feel kind of bad about feel feel bad for
big bear here okay
owen benjamin has a um
he has a stalker like a legit star like
this isn't like a
a bit or anything he has a legit stalker
how about this you want to read the
first paragraph i'll get the second one
sure okay go ahead oh her name is uh
kate i am
goddess and queen uh queen b bear uh
i she yeah she says uh i'm in
sandpoint met owen and he ran for me
like he was scared or on
edge well it's just okay we're we're
already off yeah
don't approach people you know from the
internet yeah she was probably chasing
him like the uh
remember the fake jessica rabbit yeah
yeah yeah
uh but yeah anyway she she goes on to
say
uh uh
like oh like i was on cia angelina or
whatever i don't know what that means
when i tried to show my id he reacted
like i was reaching for a weapon why
were you showing him your id
i don't know uh at the post office i
think i know why
and he just ran from the very elder
slash
guide he speaks of i am the elder
whoa whoa whoa whoa this is [ __ ]
i am the table yeah this is
this is some really creepy [ __ ] i am the
elder
i am so disappointed owen behaved just
like those he makes fun of
so he doesn't want to be called out like
he claims bet not we'll see if he really
walks his talk
okay this one's oh i love her what is
she carmine junior now
look a pint of gold is worth more than a
gallon of blood
um i had
oh my god this is crazy i had gravy
that makes his look like soup but he
rejected me after telling everyone to
help old people in need
sounds good but did he do it no
he left me standing there defenseless
after being robbed
after just to standpoint offering me
money i wasn't asking for
i was told to go by god oh no
i left a three-bedroom place and planned
to offer it to the smiths
owen and his wife i don't know
um and uh pat
rent paid till february uh to go help
amy
which is now looking like i might lose
my section eight
guaranteed monthly rent to 1500 i need
to transfer it to bonner
county i chose to travel the dark place
and want to escape
and i need help now i am reaching out
and then for some reason
oh that's i guess that's the end yeah so
continues here from kate i am goddess
and queen bee bear
happy holidays lopez i'm in uh sam point
idaho now so she moved from washington
to idaho from everything i've seen
she's talking to you it's a very common
last name but yes
no she's not talking to me i mean he's
not talking to me this someone sent this
to me
after a long scary trek across
washington state
uh looking for owen in snow now who is
was sick like his wife amy and i've
been to that post office he spoke of
lol please relay to him i am his friend
slash sister
it will be a win-win-win-win situation
you will see and you can see a big part
of it too
my ideas are huge like the pipe organ
for healing organs and signing
and singing singing bowls singing bowls
and marb marmas marbus
marimbas marimbas uh and so much
more i am a medical intuitive oh a
medical intuitive yeah that means you
don't go to the doctor no i'm not an
actual doctor
i did run into owen at that very post
office but he got scared like i was cia
or something and took off
i love my smith family i am high iq
too i challenge owen to challenge me
my iq please follow him at owen benjamin
comedy
he has so much to teach young men we
have the same
target youtube audience males 34 to 53
is me
hope your sadness is lifted much love
and where were these left uh they were
left
as it looks like they were youtube
comments
yeah but like nobody knows what account
or anything i think her account
because it looks like her account
because oh see how it's highlighted
it looks like her account you're right
yeah so here's a little super cut that
someone put together let me plug them
uh it's a still nacho friend still nacho
friend so check this out
okay guys and i need help i need
two bears to form a trinity with me
and help me to get to the smiths
in ursa manor east amy needs help
i need to get to help amy
she is i'm psychic i know she's hurting
and she needs
you didn't know she was psychic that's
why you you feel like an idiot now you
feel like a big idiot you're not the one
that brought it to the show i'd
say you feel like an idiot okay you know
what we both feel pretty stupid
lady listen cat i was always on board
with you
help she's probably overwhelmed with
testosterone too guys
so whoever can help me get there i'm
gonna offer them my services as
a nanny as my 50-year
career in the healing arts
and yams obviously and help them to heal
so help me to get close the fridge
because i mean you're just gonna that
first of all lettuce goes bad very
quickly if you don't put that in the
fridge
there's a reason you got to put it in
the crisper it's a whole thing
her doors are open or crispers are open
everything's a mess
ever can help me please
god bless you all much love
so i'm still looking for any help i can
get
from any bears i'm trying i'm not having
much
i should make some of that cincinnati
chili what is that
it's just a it's a it's a bowl of beans
look i don't know where's all these
bears we're supposed to be
hooking up with each other it looks like
when you try to make instant oatmeal and
you put way too much water in it
yeah and you go well this is ruined you
need to put more you gotta go get
another packet of oatmeal and you're
like well now i gotta play alchemist for
an hour
along the bear trail and i'm not too far
from where owen
left from gig harbor i'm i don't know a
couple or
three hours maybe a couple three hours
away three hours
hey you know you gotta get head up there
to uh
sand point it's a couple three hours
away
i'm north of there so near bellingham
washington
so if there's any bears there it can be
male female
i have a car i will pay for the gas i
will
i will compensate you all i can think
about is the philly tardo
let me tell you a couple three things
okay one
forget about eric nimmer okay two
forget about carrington bear who goes
back goes out to jersey never comes
back forget about my kid brother
anyways it's gonna be a little dark here
we're just putting stuff out you know it
would have been great
by the way can i just i think royce
knows what i'm going to say you know it
would have been great
is if mr [ __ ] music video producer
whoever you are
didn't add the music yeah like i get it
i get the joke i get the joke based on a
[ __ ] 20 year old song but like jesus
christ
this would have been great if you just
cut the super cut together
it's kind of like and it's just annoying
hearing that loop is he play it for 29
minutes for this video too
to go because i'm heading to idaho
she so she now she's leaving washington
to idaho because owen moved from what
i'm picking up
i'm trying to get out of here i need
help
i'm trying to reach out to a couple
bears there's got to be
bears in this area in washington near
well there's literal bears
[Music]
uh
go up for the very man
that i'm mad at for reporting me
two times and getting me into this bind
i'm in
that i'm having to find a place to live
when i'm not doing well at all you know
i'm not
well i mean you know usually those
things are all interconnected right it's
like
hence why you're probably going to lose
your your home
thank you all for your prayers
and and love and light and goodness and
just sending me all kind of good
vibrations i actually felt them and it's
helping me to
get strong and straighten up so what
she sent owen a letter have yourself
a very merry christmas that's not the
word a merry little christmas no that's
not the words oh and i thought you were
a
song guy
i'm sure those aren't the words
it seems they've always been and would
always be friends time
cannot change but not that oh fool
dear stone and amy hello i am
something a cat a healer who felt the
call to come
um yeah oh you know what he did
he read ahead a little bit and now he's
it's red ahead a little bit and he's
like
uh oh uh oh this is not the first time
owen has received something in the mail
oh
started reading ahead and went remember
the guy with the manifestos
yes i was like yeah dude i'm a bear too
we need to [ __ ] take action we need
to do [ __ ] man
it's time to start these [ __ ] like owen
was just like reading and he's like
yeah i am a fellow bear and i think we
all need to rise up and
take him so anyway thank you for the
letter
he just amazing grace that was so funny
i remember that one
it's like you know we should rise up and
conditions awesome romney
you know what we're not going to read
this letter on the air thanks guys
look at his face
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ]
he's literally that is he just went
through
the five stages of death in in one shot
right there
that oh that's [ __ ] you can you
please just see that again
not the whole thing but just as he's
reading it i just wanna do this
cats a healer who felt the call to come
um hello
darkness my old friend went through the
five stages of death
he went bargaining grief
acceptance like just all there i want to
say that i
i in this situation i do feel bad i do
feel heavy i feel
active no of course obviously it's funny
but i also feel bad for him
oh [ __ ]
oh that was so many that was an
emotional
listen to the mumbles after this watch
you miss watches
oh
oh no this is a roller coaster of
emotions
oh yeah this way i'm just gonna um
this lady came up to me this morning
actually and really was jarring so
i i didn't ask for a healer in my life
um i wasn't even gonna talk about it but
you sent a
card you're you're not on a mission from
god
to come to me okay
you're you're being very crazy
so um thank you but no thank you
all right um yeah i went to the post
office this morning this way it was like
oh and i'm like all right
uh it's like i'm on a mission to heal
you i'm like why don't you heal yourself
how does that sound
um i don't want anything to do with that
so i mean honestly i don't blame them in
the ways
and and you know this is i there's a lot
of people that'll say like owen did this
to himself but it's like honestly
there really is no excuse for this like
parasocial
behavior that so many people exhibit
like
it's you you do a show like even with
even if you're owen and you're trying to
cultivate a cult
or even if you're just a game streamer i
mean i'm sure even the quartering has
people that come up to him and make him
uncomfortable it's like
you know what i mean like it's it says
johan saying he did this to himself but
he but
it's one thing to to stream your crazy
[ __ ] right
whatever crazies might but for a crazy
to show up at your post office
and then to expect like again this is a
problem with streaming communities right
is a lot of you guys
spend hours a day with the same dude
and most of you guys are fine with it
well so you guys do your thing you watch
the show like any other dude and you're
like that's a good show whatever
but there are other people out there
that that are that
they're they're like logging all of that
time mentally like
to them that's like time we've spent
together
and then they get really like dejected
and angry when they're like
whoa oh what oh so now you're gonna be a
[ __ ] [ __ ] and you're like
dude i don't know you you know and like
i
do kind of feel bad for owen you know
has he been his own worst enemy 100
is this hilarious 110 it's funny
but there's also an element where you
kind of do feel bad for the guy
you're you're indulging yourself it has
nothing to do with me
so just know that that's if if you would
come up to my wife in that situation
she would probably have like gripped her
knife
so you're not helping anybody yeah i
healing rape i even said that
i said what you're doing right now is
very rapey
all right doing a helen keller on you
how dare you
oh yeah yeah stranger date yeah but it's
like it's the energy it's like
hey i'm coming to help no no
we don't allow people that we know
around our kids without us
you have a mask on no yeah and that's
the other thing that i think should be
brought up even if you think
you know when it's all these things like
it's not his kid's fault and it's not
his wife's fault like why are you
bothering them
you know in public well no exactly
exactly
again i mean for you know because i do
see you know there's people that just
say you know you can't feel bad for
him whatever it's like look i i reserve
my lack of empathy for like murderers
and pedophiles and people that do
really bad things uh globalist chinese
people
but like owens just a crazy like i think
sometimes people sort of
forget that owen is also crazy right
like
i get that he's in on it he knows the
grift and stuff and i get that he's
he's not a good man i'm not sitting here
defending him and saying he's a good man
but i mean nobody deserves to be stalked
and feel unsafe in their own home that's
just that's kind of weird you know
she's fine she's harmed she appears to
be harmless but
um that's it's a really crazy
thing like most people that haven't been
in the public eye or a lot of people
don't know them they don't understand
what it's like to be approached by
strangers on the street
who feel they know you really really
well and you don't know them at all
okay and i'm actually really good at it
because i like people
and when people are like oh man you know
and i'm like yeah what's up dude
but this whole like i've come so long
and
it's like no no no no leave now
all right i'll be honest though i'm
surprised
he's playing the piano of course it's
his go-to yeah try to break the tension
yeah the guy now for 20 years
no not that long maybe 18 years
of people coming up to me on the street
randomly and uh
and so there's a whole spectrum of it
and and that level of like
fanaticism and like i'm set on a mission
to find you
you have to understand it's it's
horrible to to be around that
and oh no i just have to convince you
that i'm going to heal you you're not
going to heal [ __ ]
you you got to work on yourself why
would anyone think that that approach
would be well received
uh insanity you know because in your
mind
you like because in in people's minds
sometimes they talk to me and
they think oh what and there can be a
healthy element of that
and then there's no there is there is no
healthy element to that
unless the only exception if you guys
want to talk to us
through the computer is if you're just
yelling something at the screen
because you're angry one of us you go
that's not the way it works you [ __ ]
idiot but no oh and if they're having
entire conversations with you
in their mind there's no there is no
healthy level of that that's a very
unhealthy thing
right the deranged element where people
are like
if only i know that you understand only
you will understand
when you get in someone's face and and
you're real desperate and crazy
it's not healthy you're trying to take
something from me you're not
giving to me and then i felt guilt
like on christmas eve did i really turn
my back on a
desperate woman you know and i didn't
because she was trying to get something
from me
it wasn't organic but
i would have you know i do i do feel a
little guilt
that i couldn't help but my obligation
is to
myself and my family above crazy people
but um because you know she what she
wanted from me
wasn't something i could give her
you know i just didn't want to be around
that person anymore because i could see
the crazy in her eyes it was really
crazy
and i know in her mind everything it
didn't she has so much to tell me and it
didn't go well and all this stuff
and i do have um sympathy and empathy
for that i do i would love
if that woman felt better but um
you know i'm just don't come up to me in
strange places and act like that
because then she reached in her pocket
and pulled out something and i was like
and that's what i took off i'm like what
is that in your hand
because it's like people want to kill
you you crazy person ran into a crazy
person
yeah from being fair here right sounds
like you're both a little crazy
sometimes if they love you so much you
know
and guys it was really deranged really
deranged
like worse than i'm even describing it
because i don't want to embarrass people
somebody says post office isn't strange
it is well no it is but here's the
reason why
you got to remember something owen has
been banned off of all these platforms
so
they know that owen's going to go to the
post office a lot to get his uh
his checks and his letters and stuff i'm
sure he goes at least once a week right
because that's how
he gets his payments and stuff so this
isn't just like she happened to be at
the post office and he was there
she was waiting for him at the post
office
this is her again here i am
[Music]
at the
[Music]
dude she's legitimately like crazy like
this isn't like
kind of crazy this is like schizophrenic
okay hi guys this is the room
i'm leaving oh fancy standpoint
[Music]
this is my view and you can see my
how it changed i'm going to do a part
two here so you can see what i
manifested in just a couple of days
like magic is she doing spells
i guess change this whole thing around
these people here these hindu people
here grabblers
she's even got the language she's got
the lingo down royce
not grapplers travelers not grabblers
for the worst
or just awful the owner walked in
my room without knocking when i was
naked
they're all the help quit
nobody wants to work here so there's no
service but no discount for that
but anything extra you want you're at a
day's end you're lucky the toilets are
flushed
yeah seriously you're lucky there's a
human being at the front desk
and not just like some bulletproof glass
that you're getting yeah
god they're gonna really chalk it up for
you
so there's so many things here and now i
found out that there's black
mold in here no wonder everyone's
getting sick
i've been getting sicker and sicker
since i got here and i felt good did you
get mad black mold on your brain
this oh my god it's
this woman is a [ __ ] nightmare holy
[ __ ] dude
when i got here so now i'm leaving to go
to a different
uh inn down the road and i will show you
the difference
between this and that and the other
one's actually cheap
look at the cedars the cedars and out my
window
hopefully i can heal and do what i got
to do to get myself
prepared for my continuing journey here
so we're continuing today oh no two more
she drove across the country to idaho
for the guy who was in sullivan son
the sidekick not the main guy not even
the man not burns not burn
the cramer of sullivan she drove across
the country
weeks till i'm officially homeless and
that's like dude i'm sorry but sandpoint
idaho
like that i wouldn't go there for [ __ ]
like guaranteed [ __ ] like if a hot
chick in idaho i was like you come here
i'll circuit it's like i don't know
that's a [ __ ] long trek
this woman went for owen and then i i
love that she's bringing up that she's
going to be homeless soon we'll maybe
don't trek across the country
and get a days in and she gave up her
section 8 housing
in washington because she said that in
the letter remember she gave up her
section 8
housing so she had a guaranteed home to
go follow owen
living off her credit but
i don't know i've been homeless before
and actually i was pretty happy then
mike she drove across the country for
the guy who did that
stole my bike the what stole my bike
grinch nice nice call back
thank you
on friday harbor
and uh
where else when i left canada friday
harbor
then i don't know pittsburgh
and then what do you do like you're just
a crazy person alone with your crazy
thoughts
at the at the days in at sandpoint iowa
idaho like that sounds
depressing well it sounds like everybody
had any days in
nobody nobody's out of day's inn has
ever been there for a good reason
go down the front desk get yourself a
six dollar can of pringles
go back up watch some forensic files
maybe it's one of those fancy days it's
attached to a denny's
oh nice go right back down that's
probably more of a waffle house that's a
waffle house stays in you're right
you're right
california in washington
so my lease is officially up on january
31st i still have my section eight but
probably go out there and take care of
that
go back home lady you have a car
go back home did she think that owen was
gonna say live with me why not
what i don't know where i'm going to use
it
but i want to be on a piece of land
i want a homestead with owen and the
bears and
amy dear mister i'm too good to live
with your fans
dude i listen to that i want to be with
owen and the
but this this is not great
not great
bears are you i'm like bear target
supporters ever so i might be going live
i might
start doing more serious videos but i
got some healing to do here so
any help love good vibes prayers
whatever you want to send me
i'll be taking your gifts
much love to all
good morning everyone now this is more
recent
cat here showing you my morning view
i'm living in a field yeah what is this
it looks like a place where people dump
like just dump garbage
it looks like in fargo where they
kidnapped his wife too
it's a [ __ ] wood chipper out on the
right side yes
from my new home in my car
where i'm freezing she is living in her
car i feel like i have frostbite on my
big
toe of my left foot no
thanks to owens rejection of me
what what's the matter royce
she's blaming him for her situation well
it's his fault look owen has a lot of
things that we make fun of and burning
dinosaur books and bertare and all that
stuff
and not letting his fans live with him
this isn't oh this isn't you're
this isn't owen's fault lady no it
didn't i mean he should have let her
live there and be his nanny
and handle his children
he's not helping me at all i
sent him at least a half a dozen letters
mr uh good guy letting me freeze to
death
in sandpoint idaho while he continues
his non-stop e-begging for money
oh now he's in ebay oh see now he's
now see here it is this is where now i'm
gonna i'm gonna lose my sympathy for
this lady
because this is what they all do royce
this is what they all do
they love you until you [ __ ] firm
with them until you establish boundaries
and then all of a sudden you're a
[ __ ] e-beggar you're a loser
but like why did you give up your house
and all of your things to drive across
country
to to be a nanny for an e-beggar why why
wasn't he
why weren't you aware of the fact that
he was an e-beggar
when you loved him and then now all of a
sudden that prick didn't give me what i
wanted you
[ __ ] loser you e begger you scumbag
these i'm telling you man these people
are sick man
i'm living homeless in my car
for money not even him
yet he continues to beg
for money mr hollywood
you can well mr sandpoint idaho
which by the way is the new hollywood a
lot of people say that
and let's be honest when he was in
hollywood it was really more mr anaheim
he didn't live in hollywood he was
[ __ ] he was mr burbank yeah mr
bourbon
studio city guys it's a better airport
oh look at mr fancy pants mr culver city
over here
take the man out of hollywood but you
can't take the hollywood out of the man
yes yes i'm sure he's living next to
bruce willis and tom cruise
well the reason idaho the reason you
can't take the hollywood out of the man
is because they were raped in hollywood
as children jesus christ dude
i'm saying this because i'm basing it on
his
quote 11 11
a.m on january 8 2021
he said and i quote
you cannot be disappointed by me
it is not possible that is not
true mr owen benjamin
smith who continues to ignore me as he
keeps
begging people for money she's by the
train tracks she's a literal hobo train
track person now
but you drove all the way out there and
you begged him to live with him
again like this is because when i when i
said it earlier a couple people were
like yeah but owen is an e-beggar
but that's not the point i'm making the
point i'm making
is that this woman like many other sick
people on the internet like many other
overly attached psychos on the internet
they love you
and they love you and they love you and
they love you and they love you and the
minute you go hey
that's not cool it's making me
uncomfortable and
you i you know people i don't owe you
that
then it's all of a sudden you're a big
piece of [ __ ] you're a liar you're
[ __ ]
grifter you're an e-beggar it's
these [ __ ] people man these sick
people
so he can live nice and warm while i
freeze the [ __ ] death
huh a win owen doesn't
mike i don't i'm gonna defend him i
can't believe this is happening but owen
doesn't owe you
anything yeah he does his name is
literally owen
i'm done with the show what
no i'm done i'm finished i [ __ ] hate
you i hate you
i hate all this maybe she was confused
by his name no i'm done
[Laughter]
i [ __ ] hate you
everyone likes a good pun
piece of [ __ ] you piece of [ __ ]
that was so quick and it made me so
angry
[ __ ] you
i mean if his name was flowing she would
have showed up to challenge him to a rap
battle but it's not
his name his name was bowen she expect a
plane from him
seen him twice in the post office
you approached him a second two times
you approached him a second so the first
time
he ran away panicked and you figured
you know what second to do she thinks
she's phil connors
does she still does she think she gets a
redo every day
she's just like i'll just keep trying
until he falls in love with me
she starts learning piano
needle knows owen i asked your sister to
prom
behind me
as if somebody by the way because carlos
says this is 100 owen's fault he created
a cult of re
it while owen has
a degree of culpability in this
to say that he's a hundred percent at
fault and deserves to have crazy people
stalk him at his local post office is
like you can you we look there's plenty
of things we criticize about owen
there's no owen fans in this
in on this panel but it's it's also kind
of shitty
to just dismiss it and go oh yeah he
deserves to have crazy people stalk his
family
yeah [ __ ] it right like that's i'm sorry
man i don't agree there i just don't
agree i don't agree that
because [ __ ] one percent of you out
there
can't differentiate between the internet
and real life
that people's kids and their wives need
to be uncomfortable now
no man uh moe says are we sure it's not
michaela peterson that's making these
videos
and he refuses to talk to me you know
now i'm going to apologize to god that
made this video i think this video is
just in her head the whole time
the music yeah oh my god
now so somebody just said uh we don't
know how much money she's giving him
again not my problem not owen's problem
she probably shouldn't have done that
probably shouldn't have done that do you
know how many people that don't have
money that always give money and i tell
them to stop giving money because they
don't have money and i'm like please
don't do that
like it's great if i'm you know i always
equated like doing the show to
the guy playing the piano at the bar and
some people are gonna have their dinner
and eat and have a couple drinks and
leave
some people have cash on them and walk
by and real quick you're like hey man
good work man you know you walked into
penn station i don't always put money in
the musicians thing but sometimes
you got a couple bucks and you can spare
it it's it's
but if you're giving your livelihood to
online people
you deserve to freeze to death in your
car in idaho you deserve that
what's happening i get to talk about
all he does come on
bears come defend him ah come defend him
be
begging like that but
thousands and thousands of dollars from
people a month while i
stop he's in trouble man
this turned to anger super fast i'm
losing weight
every day freezing to death i am
69 years old and here's another 59
years old nice
nice nice but like
wow and you know by the way to be an old
well 69 it's not super but it's old to
be an
old white woman imagine being an old
white woman in heaven
nowhere to go there's yeah okay there's
a chance maybe her family died off she
doesn't have any help whatever but
most people that are homeless and like
nobody wants to help them they have
nobody they can reach out to
they're usually people that have are so
far gone
people just cannot stand this person
anymore so
to be a 69 year old white woman living
in your car
because you've stalked owen benjamin and
now you got nowhere to go
just shows you what a what a waste of a
life this woman has
been what a waste of 69 years on this
planet
a quote from mr benjamin
if you see or know of an
older person needing help you help them
yeah you [ __ ] you know maybe go hey
you know let me let me let me give you a
couple bucks or something
you you don't take them into your home
no and have him live with you
and also if you drove all the way to
[ __ ] orlando or tampa
and said hey marsh uh i know you don't
really know me but i watched the show
i really need money my response would be
wait and you needed money so you
left your house drove all the way to
florida stopped at like nine
gas stations and then your your plan was
to ask me for a couple bucks
while you're staying in a days inn
you're not good at managing
money if that was your plan
he's letting me freeze to death in my
car
ignoring every single letter i have
written him
given him multiple opportunities to
respond to me
opportunities he has my email he has my
he had where i was staying on credit
that i can no longer stay at these
hotels
charging 60 dollars a day
i'm on so it's really cheap for a hotel
actually god i bet this idiot probably
responded
trying to be nice yeah probably got
himself like like there are people that
write me
cr not even like bad emails but just
crazy emails or like long emails or like
lots of emails
i just still read all of them you just
can't like it's
it's it's honestly unfair to ask
somebody
to read like four emails a week from you
when you times that by a thousand people
you know what i mean when people just
start
hitting you up all the time over every
little thing and you know that that's
what this woman's been doing
and you know he's probably been nice
before and been like yeah you know
that's cool hey good luck
you know with that stuff and then it's
like owen said good luck
clearly he meant come to idaho and move
in with me
social security and disability
and i only get 800 and some
a month i even posted it on my channel
showing the actual amount i get in my
ninety dollars
he won't even let the muting is they're
meeting at her personal information just
so you guys know what that meeting is
also i didn't say i didn't point out
anybody specifically but i will bet you
guys ten dollars that
uh by the time i get home tonight i will
have four emails from four separate
people going
hey i'm sorry i'm always sending emails
all the time let me know if it's
too much emails this is
but this is one of the emails
help on his farm
the only begging i've done is asking him
to let me come
help on the farm oh we'll let you
live with him see i love these sick
people i love how these people
dismiss um uh
like i love when people kind of twist
something and go like no i'm helping
it's like
you ever see the guy that goes uh yeah
i'm living with my mom i'm back living
with my parents
i'm helping them out they've been going
through you see that guy that's like 30
and they're like yeah i'm living with my
mom and she needed help and stuff you
know
grocery shopping and stuff getting
around and then you see their mom and
their mom's like
fit is a fiddle totally fine and you're
like so you're helping out your mom huh
you needed to
needed to help your dad's up on the roof
with a ladder fixing the satellite dish
you're like
they seem pretty spry dude what are you
you're helping him out huh yeah you're
staying in your old room with a third
eye blind poster on the wall
a dmx poster and you're like yeah
no i'm here helping out you know they've
been going through a lot and then you
see them and they're like we're fine we
literally have a more of an active
social life than we did when we had you
living here the cows and the goats and
help
amy who needs help he's so friggin
selfish
when i said i got a
psychic call to come help amy
right which psychic call
totally normal said i didn't call for
healing
well it ain't about you owen everything
isn't about
you oh god so the universe is driving
you would you say that the universe
drives these things not you that you're
powerless to stop them
is that what you're implying ma'am ma'am
i honestly got to a point where i go she
can't get crazier but she's been
she's getting worse yeah she's getting
crazier and crazier and then sheok
writes in the chat lol
he's selfish which by the way he is
but like this is hilarious to me that
the her angle is he's selfish because he
because he wouldn't let me come help him
and it's like no you just want to live
here
what are you going to do now huh you got
on you knowing exactly what you're doing
while i'm freezing in my car
i have like frost
no thanks to you thanks for all the help
she's covering the mic i think with
their hand is what's happening
because you can kind of hear a little
bit in the back what are you going to do
about it
huh wait don't people get wind of this
i mean but we're getting wind of it are
you gonna and we actually feel bad for
him
yeah are you going to expose owen as a
guy who just wants to do his streams
and doesn't want people showing up to
his house because that's that makes him
i'll be honest
frankly pretty relatable we got wind of
it and we're the target audience that
loves making fun of owen we love making
fun of owen so if if we're saying
lady you need to [ __ ] relax you
probably need to [ __ ] relax
you are deceiving people
as you go on your merry little way yeah
it's like relief owen's the defendant
here
i feel like the judge going god damn it
judge me for the defendant
yeah i can't do this like i can't
believe i had today
i can't believe you made lady you're
making me side with owen benjamin
and it ain't even [ __ ] wednesday yet
okay
this is gonna be a weird week talking
about how everybody's under the spell
well i'm wet and i'm saying
you're under this spell
everybody else while you laugh at them
and ban them for life
how many people have committed
because you banned them for life well i
mean if you commit
being banned from an owen benjamin chat
room instead of just making a new
youtube name
that's kind of natural selection right
wouldn't rice
royce let's say one of your favorite
youtubers banned you from the chat would
you
a just leave probably just leave
b make another youtube account or c
literally yourself probably just leave
mike i'd be like
i don't care it's not that important
it's just youtube
are you hearing me i wish everyone i
banned
life would be so much easier mr smith
mr smith goes to north idaho
huh you led me here by your work
no you said the spirits you said
with the universe you said well spirits
of the universe yeah you said
they they drive you
what are you gonna say to me huh that
i'm crazy
he already said to you please go away
and yes ma'am
um please no offense here but you're
[ __ ] lunatic
because you're exposed let's see what
people think of mr hollywood now
you ain't doing nothing but collecting
money from people
and isn't that what you were doing with
the government yeah it's i mean section
8
aren't you i mean say what you want
about owen at least he has to hit the
go live button and you know he has to
you know he's opening up letters he
might get a paper cut i mean he's
actually doing more than you are still
not your friend the guy who
who actually cut this video up it's in
the chat thank you for this by the way
we do appreciate it this is great this
is i i didn't even know this woman
existed but this is fantastic
claiming you're such a great guy when
you're letting this happen
to a 69 year old woman
[ __ ] nice why don't you just
like this is what you should do when
these crazies come at you
at this point it'll be self-defense i
mean i mean if you play this in front of
a [ __ ] jury
because i'm a boomer or because i'm a
i know you got issues with them why
don't you deal with your mommy issues
huh
why don't you get over them again why
don't putting it on other women
then why why if you knew all this right
this is my point and this is you know
this happens with
internet fans it happens in
relationships with women
um where you know you have a
disagreement let's say
but now they've got a whole dossier of
[ __ ] they're ready to attack you about
and it's like okay but if all this
stuff's been bothering you
why don't you bring these things up as
they happen
but a lot of these people and this is
the way
humans are just emotionally [ __ ] now
in america but
people do this thing where they like you
and they like you and they like you and
one time you say no to them or rebuff
them
all of a sudden they remember all these
things they hate about you and it's like
well if that stuff was in the back of
your mind or in the front of your mind
when you liked me so much why did you
like me why did you try to attach
yourself to this community
why did you try to come all the way to
sandpoint idaho to live in my house
if i was a woman hating i hate my mom
and i hate women
and mr hollywood i'm a e-beggar i'm a
grifter all that right but like
why is that all uh occurring to you now
i don't know maybe it's because owen
teamed up with national
is that what it is i think he was the
third man and then
six shut up yeah and then he went back
because nobody cares boomers yeah
there's a lot of dumb down boomers
through all this [ __ ] and i see through
your [ __ ] too
so uh let's see what happens
now huh well i keep telling about what
you're really doing in
real life because i'm here to see
it dude i'm here to see it i'm here to
see it dude
listen here brother you told me i was
gonna go live on your farm
and we were gonna be hanging and banging
dude but now here i am freezing to death
in sandpoint idaho
and i'm sick of it i ain't having it no
more
i'm letting people know how you really
treat people while you tell them
what to do and how to treat people
how to treat older people you help them
it depends on the old person yeah
frankly
too bad too bad for you
that you got eyes on you you're scared
to death of me i saw it in your eye whoa
i'm scared of you
a big dog and a little skinny me
only 104 pounds dude
stop staying too skinny first of all
stop
dropping thousands of dollars on your
stays at days in
okay stop staying at the maybe stop
staying at the finest hotels
six eight and two fat for your [ __ ]
good
oh now he's fat don't even know that
yeah that you're a soy
soy boy this is what these people do and
soy boy
you might be getting over some of it and
changing
but you ain't changed enough yet to be
talking to people like that
and treating people like the way you've
treated me well i will say this ma'am is
that clearly if there's one thing
that you you have really showed us just
how irrational owen was being
and i think that's the important
takeaway from this is you know the more
i watch this the more i realize that
owen was wrong
owen should let more people like this
move in
frankly i think owen should apologize to
her you always hear an apology
oh people are going to start knowing
because i
don't lie well except then
and then and then and then
talk about your wrath well that's my one
sin i got left
and that's what you're gonna get is my
wrath
that's a threat right call me a sinner
if you want that's a threat
you're gonna feel my wrath i think
clearing of my pineal
is is this threat right there's no
question about it
she sounds like a promo talking to a
[ __ ]
my third eye can see really really well
you know that is ironic man because i
was gonna say you're probably on crystal
meth
yeah so
to keep you from making a fool of
yourself and you keep
talking and talking so you're going to
have a lot
of retracting to do unless you want to
just let people
let it slide and not let people know
that you
misled them like you misled me you
misled me
all the way from birch bay water
back from that ledge my friend because
it's a days inn and you can't get that
window open anyway
barbar your little ursa manor
i am here in standpoint
items they don't let you go outside at
poor people hotels
because four people are really sad
they don't let you climb things cause
they're afraid you're sad
you are looking people you are looking
at the mountain
schweitzer mountain over 6 000
uh feet and i am suffering in this high
altitude and cold
and owen is not me not
helping this older person he helped
everybody else to help
this is the neediness that that that
these communities foster sometimes like
again it's always there's 99 cool people
and there's always that
one person that feels that they're
emotionally owed something and it's
it's the problem too
is with covet um [ __ ] locking down it's
making things worse
um but this computer thing now nobody
goes out nobody has any real friends
nobody goes out to the bar with people
and just has a normal drink
everybody's life is on the internet and
some
people just don't learn any social
cues and this is what happens some
people just go you [ __ ] owe me pal
okay i i we spend hours a day together
and you're like
but we don't i do a show i i use obs
and then you open up your laptop so yeah
this woman is
terrified how long has this been going
on well it's i mean
the video starts from december 20th but
i mean i'm assuming this has been going
on before that
jesus